haha the Joe Rogan experience you done
the flow tank I did that once I did not
like that at all
I lost her phobic no no I just was I
couldn't I couldn't get into any kind of
zone or vibe I just kept like I'm laying
here in lukewarm water I'm like I'm not
hearing anything I was like no my thing
am i liking this it's getting a little
cold or doe it's getting warm right so I
couldn't I couldn't well that is a real
issue if it's not temperature control
correctly and you feel cold it'll [ __ ]
up your experience you really want it in
that perfect sweet zone but when you can
get there it's really all about whether
or not you know how to concentrate on
breathing if you can just concentrate on
breathing dumb breath work yeah it's
very interesting it's not out not a
difficult formula that I employ but I'll
tell you guys if you listen if you also
float when I get in there I touch the
sides to Center myself so that I don't
bounce against anything and distract
myself because I'm floating you know and
you drift into the wall sometimes so I
wait until the ripples die down cuz when
you climb in there's gonna be like a
little bit of ripple edge right and then
when you lay down once the water gets
still then I let my hands go and then I
just think about breathing and I thought
I'm not a wizard at this right it goes
in and out I think about I forgot to
call that guy I gotta send that email oh
I got a I got a booked I gotta put that
on my calendar I keep forgetting and
then if I just stay vigilant and make
sure okay okay get back on the road and
the bet the road is thinking only of the
breathing only of the in and out and in
and out I just like visualized air
coming in and out of my lungs and just
that alone while lying in the tank would
put me in a trance it takes a while but
I can do it quicker because I've done it
for years because it's like the tanks a
normal thing I get in I'm like hob the
most I always think is I should do this
more often that's what I usually think
but I can get into trance by just
thinking about the breathing
[Applause]